so success is the progressive
realization meaning this is your goal
that you want to hit this is where you
are as long as you're closing the gap
you're successful the minute you stop is
that you perceive it as failure but it's
really feedback telling you to pivot so
find something that is ideal your goal
that you're in love with and just keep
progressing towards it
is your youtube channel at the point
where you need to make a decision does
it need to become your full-time gig are
you at the point where you are putting
in the hours on your youtube channel and
you just feel like man if i could just
put in the time this could go amazing
well in today's episode i've got ben
azadi from our video ranking academy and
he's going to be sharing with you his
steps to going full time on youtube with
his channel now did you know that being
a content creator is one of the fastest
growing small business types and in
today's episode we're going to be
breaking down how to make that happen my
name is heather torres and i am the host
of this think media podcast the number
one podcast to help you grow your
influence on youtube and then turn that
influence into a high impact and a high
profit online business and today's
episode is brought to you by
createwiththink.com
it is time for you to start monetizing
your youtube channel with online courses
we've partnered with thinkific to
provide you with the tools and training
you need to start monetizing your
audience off of youtube you can get
started today with your own course
creation journey at createwiththink.com
now let me introduce to you ben azadi
ben azadi is one of our success students
inside of video ranking academy he is on
a mission to help one billion people
become healthy and he's doing this
through being a best-selling author of
four books including his new book
ketoflex being the founder of keto camp
which is a global brand bringing
awareness to ancient healing strategies
such as keto dieting and fasting and he
is the creator of keto camp youtube
channel with over 6 million views today
he's gonna be sharing with you his five
tips for growing his youtube channel
into a full-blown business
[Music]
well then i am so excited that you are
finally on our podcast uh we've known
each other now for two and a half years
um because you've been a part of our
programs and in our community and i'm
just so pumped that you get to share
your story with the think community and
all the things that you're doing and
today we're talking about how you turned
your youtube channel into a business
tell me a little bit ben about your
youtube channel yeah heather thank you
for having me love think media love what
you guys are doing and it's just a
matter of time before i came to vegas to
hang out with you so yeah i mean my
company's keto camp we're a global brand
the mission at keto camp is to educate
and to inspire a billion people to help
them wake up and understand how amazing
their body is it's capable of healing so
we do that through youtube and of course
i've learned that from you and sean and
the whole team
two and a half years ago actually going
on three years is when we launched our
youtube channel
and
we're focusing on educating primarily on
ketosis and intermittent fasting but
we're niched into the ketogenic
lifestyle and as you know it's pretty
much a niche and a lot of people know
about keto so that's what we're doing
the company is called keto camp and
that's our mission i am so excited i am
a binge watcher i watch so much of your
stuff and i'm excited because you came
to youtube and you didn't quite have a
business yet this was really the entry
point into this empire that you're
building i'm calling it an empire just
so you know
the empire that you're building at keto
camp so walk me through what that
journey looked like for you when you
came to youtube what did you have ready
and how did you know what videos you
even wanted to make
so when i
launched the youtube channel i was clear
on what i wanted to talk about which was
keto so i was clear on the niche and
then i just recorded 10 videos on the
topic that i was getting questions about
when it came to keto recorded 10 videos
and just dripped those videos out two
videos per week
now in the beginning the growth was very
very slow i remember the first
six months into it i had i remember the
exact number i had 342 subscribers wow
six months into it which is great
because that's 340 people 42 people who
wanted to learn more but i had bigger
goals than that
so i remember at this time being a
little frustrated having bigger goals
than that and i just said you know i
committed to posting two times a week
i'm gonna keep this up i'm not
interested in doing this i'm actually
committed so i just kept doing two
videos a week two videos a week and all
of a sudden a video that i did called
five keto fruits you can eat all the
time just started to take off i went
from like ten thousand i kept refreshing
all day yeah twenty five thousand all of
a sudden it passed a million downloads
in in a couple of weeks so after i saw
that i just started to double down with
my content and then the channel just
started to take off so awesome now i
want to get into you brought five tips
and really your strategy of how you've
built your business around your youtube
channel but i need to ask
what did you start with did you start
with an iphone did you start with a
camera what did you start with when you
started making videos i started with the
old canon 6d camera yeah which i had a
camera like from like six years ago so i
started with that and a lavalier mic
yeah nice so it was something you
already had i already had it and i had
that camera for like five years i love
it so think this is the thing you gotta
just start with what you have it's not
about going out and getting all the cool
fancy gear it's just starting to make
videos and i love that you did that and
that you made it super simple and easy
to do well let's break down your five uh
i would say kind of your path to
building your business on youtube number
one is um you had a freemium here at
think media we call that a freemium
which just means something free to gift
to your viewers
um what was the freemium and how did you
get it going what did that look like for
you so i had the freemium done before i
even launched the channel because i knew
i wanted to promote it
it was called and it is called the keto
kickstart guide so i bought the domain
keto kickstart
pointed it to the landing page
and i created a 12-page e-book that just
broke down the basics to keto just like
the one-on-one in keto with the goal of
them wanting to learn more and then
getting them somewhere else so i had a
12 page ebook and i started to just
share that on my videos put it on the
description of the videos and just share
it all over the place to build my email
list that's awesome and that was number
two you started to build your email list
and really you know we teach this
especially here on the podcast um that
the influence that you have online is
not actually yours i mean when you think
about like your subscriber count is just
account that actually youtube owns but
when you build your email list that's
actually when you go deeper that's when
you can have a one-on-one conversation
with people that are interested in what
you're doing so talk about how you were
able to build that email list so you had
the freemium what did that look like was
that consistently in every video was
that um
emailing them every week what did that
look like for you when you quote unquote
build your email list so when they first
opted in for the free free ebook they
would give me their first name and their
email they would get automatically sent
the pdf download with a sequence of
emails so i'd have three emails that
were sent out hey this is ben thank you
so much for getting the guide and then i
would ask them a question at the end of
the email and saying stay tuned because
tomorrow i'll give you the answer to
this question so kind of like a loop to
make them want to open the next email so
i had a trigger of three emails going
out and every single day i would open or
have this open loop at the end of it on
that third email i'll say hey i'm not
gonna put you into my main list expect
to get two to three emails per week put
this in your safe senders et cetera and
i would just deliver value every week
just a lot of free value consistent
value and just developing this
relationship with them so good now the
first question that comes to mind and
maybe listeners are thinking this is
well how did you even know what to put
in the emails i mean did you come from a
copywriting background like what did you
how did you know what the email should
be about well i look at what you guys
are doing with think media okay and i
model you guys that's for sure yeah i
also read the book storybrand as well
which i know you guys recommend
something else i did by the way was take
them off of youtube to my email list and
then from my email list back to youtube
by putting a video in the actual email
so that's a fun way to get more views on
youtube yeah that's really smart we do
that a lot we do like one video a week
that's just kind of the what's happening
at think media because yeah if people
are
willing to come off of youtube they're
willing to definitely go back if you
have more value to offer so
you had something free um where were you
setting all this up was this on
different websites are you in kajabi
where were you
having everything live where does it
live in the beginning it was lead pages
okay just because i started with them
and then i got familiar with click
funnels and then i went to click funnels
and then now it's on kajabi so most of
it is on kajabi and you're running your
email through kajabi as well everything
through a combination of kajabi and
mailchimp right now okay yeah way cool
i'm kind of all over the place with the
platforms i feel you we um here at think
media what we use right now is kajabi
yeah but we're also experimenting with
other platforms because we know that it
may not be right for everyone um so
there's a lot of different platforms
that we're experimenting with with
different programs so that we can see
what that looks like but you have to
pick a platform right you have to pick
somewhere that you want to host all of
these pieces so
number three that you did so first you
had something to offer them two you
built your email list and three you
delivered value on your email list we
talked about this a little bit but one
piece that you said that was really
important was the consistency talk about
that actually just in quote unquote real
life how did you stay consistent on
doing that and making videos in real
life
consistency is king yeah and queen and
everything in between i mean
wow that was really good can we quote
that that was it's king queen and
everything in between
uh underlying venozzo
i really believe frequency creates the
genius like when i started recording
videos i sucked
and it was very uncomfortable looking
into a camera there's no eyeballs
looking at me right now it's just a
camera it's a weird situation i remember
doing live streams i would see like one
person watching two people watching and
then zero people watching and it's just
very uncomfortable but you do it enough
times
and you become more confident it's
exactly what you guys teach the
frequency creates that genius i just
kept showing up again i was not
interested i was committed i threw my
head over the fence i had to go get that
hat
so i think that's important to
understand because a lot of people are
interested in building their business
they're interested in building their
youtube channel
but we want to be committed and when
you're committed it means you do
whatever it takes and you just keep
showing up so i did that on my email
list i did it with my videos and i
learned that from you of course and
shawn and the whole team and you guys
show up all the time and it's it's very
inspirational to me wow well ben you can
be on the podcast anytime because this
flattery is amazing um so i want to talk
about it though from the perspective of
you know i'm thinking about the person
listening to this podcast right now and
they're going through
life you know maybe they've got a family
they're trying to provide for in another
career maybe they um have kids at home
and they're just trying to figure out
like how do i stay consistent and i know
you said you know it's throwing the hat
over and having to get it but
talk through that like logically for me
in the mindset that you have to have
because there's days you don't want to
get up and do it there's days that no
one opened the email you know so what
does that look like for you when you're
in those moments great question and i
know somebody's thinking that we all go
through it
reasons come before results right sean
says it all the time when you have a
strong
why your how becomes easier so i
recommend finding out what your why is
your highest values which is important
and different for every single human
being
i always say you're a masterpiece
because you're a piece of the master
because you were given a gift that
nobody else was given that same gift and
it's your highest value
so becoming clear on your highest values
and then aligning your daily actions
with that will make you unstoppable so
for me i live by my calendar and i put
on my calendar whatever is important to
me and i say no to what's not and that's
how you end up just changing your life
and staying consistent that way i
believe it now we're going to get to
more points but i need to know were you
always like this
is this like who ben has always been you
were like i see the thing i'm going
after the thing i'm going to be
consistent and send all the emails i'm
going to make the videos like is this
naturally who you are or is this
something you've grown into growing into
okay it wasn't until i got clear on my
highest values and started doing the
things that i love to do that i started
to do this consistently but before that
start quit start quit so no it's not
something i've always been doing it's
fairly uh recent last five years yeah
and that you know sean and i get this
question a lot they're like were you
just born this way and i'm like no i was
a award-winning procrastinator like that
was who i was and now i teach time
management because it's the pieces that
that you failed at that i think really
bring you into success right it's those
things that you look back on you're like
i just couldn't figure it out and then i
did and i'm just gonna keep at it and
keep at it and keep at it and that
consistency over time doing half of it
right is what actually leads to success
oh so true it's just about getting one
percent better each day
and figuring out what's important to you
my favorite definition of success came
from earl nightingale he said success is
the progressive realization of a worthy
ideal right wow say that one more time
say one more time success is the
progressive realization of a worthy
ideal
an idea excuse me an ideal is an idea
that you have fallen in love with
getting a million subscribers getting a
gold plaque becoming the best uh mom for
your children whatever that idea is
so success is the progressive
realization meaning this is your goal
that you want to hit this is where you
are as long as you're closing the gap
you're successful the minute you stop is
that you perceive it as failure but it's
really feedback telling you to pivot so
find something that is ideal your goal
that you're in love with and just keep
progressing towards it
wow that is really good and i'm going to
write that one in my journal because
that's a really good one okay so you had
something free you built an email list
you provided value to that email list
consistently over years right i mean it
wasn't like you did it once or twice it
was consistently over time um then you
provided a free value class we teach
this here at think media that you want
to provide something that's even better
right something that's going to help
lead them to the next step how did you
get to that point so when did you decide
okay i'm going to do a free class at
what time was that like six months in
three years in what did that look like
for you i started doing it about a year
into it very consistently so i would do
like a keto diet master class or
intermittent fasting master class where
it would be like an hour and a half so
it's kind of longer than a usual one i
think you guys do like an hour and a
half too well i do 45 minutes sean does
an hour and a half
so you're the you're the
so i would do like an hour and a half
master class and i would just share my
story for those who are not familiar
with my story give them all this amazing
information kind of like a fire host
sort of deal and then i would say you
know if you want more of a step-by-step
system of my coaching like here's a
one-time offer and give them a whole
bunch of benefits to signing up and
that's where i got a lot of my members
to my academy so good now when you were
doing that free class you were also then
still doing emails still doing videos
right so it's like every piece of this
is just another piece i look at it as
like legos my kids love legos we should
invest in legos we have so many of them
but it is that that piece right it's one
piece on top of the next piece on top of
the next piece so it's not like you just
jumped into making a free class but that
actually we're going to get into number
five is what led to the success you're
having right yeah exactly so the whole
progression of it like you said it
wasn't doing all this at once and i know
it could sound overwhelming it's just
you do one thing get really good at that
and then you'll stack that habit right
like the tiny habits book yeah so yeah
that led to my keto camp academy just
like you have your video ranking academy
which i've been a member of for two and
a half years and inner circle think
media inner circle which has changed my
life i have my own keto camp academy
where i offer the step-by-step system i
charge 97 per month and they also get
group coaching with me and that is where
most of my income come from comes from
and i am able to take people really help
them get off of their medication their
insulin help them reverse diabetes but
it all be it's all because of the
structure that i put into place so
that's where it all leads to that
academy for me yeah so then building the
business around your youtube channel was
offering something to sell we say you've
got to have a buy button and you chose
and there and and in one of our
trainings we teach about the money plan
which means you've got to just figure
out what is the plan to the revenue
stream right how are you going to make
money in your business and the plan that
you chose was group coaching and a
monthly membership right um how did you
decide that that was the path that you
wanted to go down and then how did you
so at the end of your web class you're
offering it are you offering it on your
youtube channel as well or do they only
hear about it behind your web class they
might hear about it on my youtube
channel if i'm doing a live stream and
somebody's asking me for my like
coaching services i would mention it but
i don't typically
sell it on my youtube channel i'll
sprinkle it in there but not necessarily
it's very uncommon
on the web class for sure i'm going to
sell i want to get everybody on there i
used to do one-on-one coaching and as
you know it's not scalable i mean it's
great you could work with somebody
one-on-one it's intimate but there's
only so many people you could help
before your bandwidth is just
spread out so i wanted to do something
in a group setting and have a system in
place like you do with your seminar
system with ketone fasting so that's
where the academy was built out which
offers group coaching with it so it's
kind of a one-two package that's really
smart now are you um you're also an
author you have a new book that just
came out tell everyone about that book
the book is called keto flex uh 311
pages of keto gold i call it hit number
one on amazon the endorsements for them
are incredible and by the way i wrote
the book with getting people into my
academy in mind which is something that
i know you're doing as well yep so i i
wrote the book and i would share i would
sprinkle in inspirational stories from
members
and then tell them hey if you want to
learn more go to ketocampacademy.com so
the book this is my fourth my fourth
book but my biggest book the date yeah
so awesome and i wanted to mention that
because it's not like you created an
academy and did a book and did all the
things and i think people don't
understand that you've been at this now
for over three years right you're at
three year mark or about around with the
youtube channel over three years but in
the health space of 11 12 years 11 and
12 years so the patience
to make all this happen talk me through
that process
the patience of having to go one step at
a time one foot in front of the other
what's that been like i don't i don't
really like the word patience oh okay
what would you like or how do you how do
you frame it i think it's important to
have patience i just don't like it i
can't i can't accept it that's what i'm
saying it's really my issue
um well understanding that
it's gonna suck sometimes right and i do
have a formula for success that i always
share
when you start to
change
first of all you become a threat to
people in your life who are not changing
it points a mirror to what they're not
doing so they're going to say things to
you why do you want to have that youtube
channel why do you want to write that
book like who do you think you are like
why do you need that fancy car so
they're going to say these things
because it's it's easier for them to
drag you down versus pull them up and
your environment is so important to give
you a really quick example of how
important your environment is i don't
think you know about this but they did a
study
on hundreds of fleas right they put
fleas in a jar and they imagine this jar
closing these fleas in and they left
them there for three days wow after
three days they removed the jar and the
fleas were still flying in the same
pattern none of them escaped because
their environment kind of shaped
their
thinking they thought they couldn't
escape not only that the fleas had
offspring and their offspring flew in
the same pattern none of them escaped in
that same little pattern wow so our
environment is important so when you
start to change you become a threat to
people in your life who don't change but
also it's gonna suck sometimes when you
have to cut ties with some people and go
on camera and feel uncomfortable but the
formula is this
suck suck suck cess yeah okay embrace
the suck keep pushing forward
failure is just something that is
perceived that is really something of a
learning opportunity so if you just look
at it that way and never give up you'll
never really fail i love that and again
let's take it back to what you said at
the beginning it's about figuring out
what your higher calling is what's your
why why are you even doing this because
every day when you have to get up and
you have to you don't have to i i truly
view youtube as a gift i mean it's a
free thing that if i just show up i can
impact people on the other side of their
screen so it's to me it's not like oh i
have to get up i have to make videos i
think the language that we use on those
things is so important and so we get to
do this you get to make this amazing
business and impact what do you want a
billion people a billion people educate
and inspire yeah educate and inspire
well my final question uh is um for
someone right now who may be at the very
beginning of this process and they
clicked on this video or they saw this
podcast title and they were like oh wow
turn your youtube channel into a
business and they're brand new to this
and
they just heard these steps that you
went through
and now they're like oh wow that's like
work that's gonna be work or i don't
know the next step i'm not sure where i
should go what is some advice you have
for that person i remember early heather
where i was listening to amy porterfield
and listening to chalene johnson and i'm
like what is an email list i don't even
know what that is what advice do you
have for that for that person that's at
the very beginning of this process
yeah great question i would say
to find somebody who's doing what you
want to do and either pay them to teach
it to you or get their free resources
that are available right so for me it
was think media right i i enrolled into
your courses and you take
decades of learning and turn that into
days so that's one option number two is
that either you think you can do it or
you think you cannot do it either way
that you're you're right
and we don't get what we want in life
necessarily we get what we are and what
we are are the 60 000 thoughts that we
think every single day
so if you change the way you look at
things you start to change the way when
you change the way you look at things
the things you look at change
so instead of seeing this as like you
said i have to do this it's i get to do
this and getting clear on your why
writing it down why it's important for
you to launch that channel all the
people you're going to help and share
that with friends as if you already have
accomplished that like you're super
excited write it in the present tense
keep it in front of you change your
environment change your thoughts and
it's just sooner rather than later
you're going to change your life i love
that so much and that to me has been the
testimony of how we've built think media
and and really where we're headed to
next is really just looking at what
we're here to do and i can't wait to see
um
what happens to your business where can
people go if they want to know more
about keto they want to follow you what
does that look like yeah and thank you
for having me here i just love what you
guys are doing uh ketocamp on youtube
campus spell with the k so keto camp
camp with the k we have our keto camp
podcast we just passed a million
downloads on there wow congratulations
thank you 111 countries like all that
came from youtube by the way because i
didn't launch the podcast until youtube
got some traction and it made the
podcast grow much faster so ketocam
podcasts and then my website's
benezotti.com awesome and we'll link all
of the resources that we talked about we
mentioned a couple books as well as our
academy we'll have all of that in the
show notes down below so make sure you
click there if you want to go further
well i hope you enjoyed that
conversation and my question to you is
are you ready to go all in on youtube
are you ready to make your youtube
channel a full-blown business are you
ready to invest in yourself and go
deeper with us here at think media if
you would like to join us on this
youtube journey you can get all the
details and the latest offer for
becoming a member of video ranking
academy down in the description of
today's episode now every single week i
love to shout out our community members
the people you who are listening to the
podcast and today's community shout out
is brought to you by win this tech.com
think media is giving away a brand new
youtube studio and all you have to do to
enter is go to win this tech dot com
fill out a simple survey that will help
us know the type of content you want us
to make and you will be entered into
when not only the microphone the
lighting but also the camera which is a
brand new sony zve10 just go to
winthistek.com and today's shout out
comes from
carol knows she says excellent podcast
think media offers such valuable content
thanks sean and heather so encouraging
well carol thank you so much for being
here every single week to listen to
these conversations and this content it
means the world to us that you would
invite us into your youtube journey and
carol thank you for rating and reviewing
the podcast over on apple podcast now i
also want to shout out someone from our
youtube channel did you know that we
have a full youtube channel dedicated to
the podcast and content just like this
you can subscribe on think media podcast
on youtube and today i want to shout out
nakisha she says i love this so
practical and i've definitely seen
growth with some of these strategies i'm
coming off of a break but working
towards 50k nakisha so excited for you
and thank you so much for being locked
in on our youtube channel and leaving
that comment it means the world to me
every week when i get to go in there and
comment back to you guys on the youtube
channel well thank you so much for
listening to today's episode and we will
catch you in the next one
you